Wesley finally a victory for you comes
in round four yesterday it felt like you
were a bit upset about the whole uh
situation but now finally you broke
through how does that feel yeah I mean
who wouldn't be upset looking to a 15
year old but as I said now at least I
know who I'm playing and uh
no longer playing a teenager bio throng
yesterday I still have to play Hans
Neiman 2019.
well I guess I've known Sam for many
years now he was the youth champion in
2018. I've played a lot of games with
him as part a lot of games with him and
you've sparked as well with him you've
trained with him yeah
I think if I went with his place in San
Francisco once in 2015 before the U.S
championship and also we were working
2014 before in Europe preparation for
the Trump Olympia uh and then
after that we played here and there like
online practice we were teammates in the
online Olympia in 2020. and uh also in
many olympiads so you know him quite
well how do you generally approach this
type of games when you know your
opponent well you know his repertoire
you know his Tendencies as well well I
don't really know if you're better but I
just it's a nice feeling when you know
someone well when I study these games I
kind of know his likes and dislikes what
he's capable of and whatnot uh so just
you know you've been around for many
years
and I remember
in 2000 2011 or something he was
wondering if he should be a jet
professional or do something else and
he's a very successful player I think he
would have done well in any field that
he'd gone to like he like I think he was
if I was correct killing the ghost
uh to have a career in finance or
something like that yeah I think he
would have made a lot more money but he
chose chess and you know yother and I
also chose Jeff it's quite fun too
sometimes you have to follow your
passions for sure and he's definitely a
very passionate uh individual when it
comes to chess yeah that's true I mean
if you're 2700 you can definitely make a
good career absolutely and let's talk
about the game he started off with the
Sicilian did you expect the neither of
uh are you expecting him to play the
Berlin something a bit more tame or it's
hard to predict yeah I mean it's in a
given they he played the neither of many
times last year but uh been playing
guitar sounds very hard to predict
because also played the French but
anyway you cannot uh spot any pattern in
his opening play well he generally plays
similar openings in the same tournament
but I think no one has
played uh wait what happened
uh no Darius played D4 against him yes
yes yeah it's hard to predict I think
generally he plays similar systems once
in the same in the same tournament yeah
so he prepares a certain system for the
tournament at hand and then plays it
throughout the year yeah that makes
sense because then you can be more
familiar well probably he's listening to
the interviewer he's like no no I have
other things in my bag the thing filled
Cup last year he was playing the night
or regularly the whole uh the whole
tournament yep yeah you came with this
idea of playing the more
uh peaceful let's say Bishop Tui do not
go into the main lines after Bishop to
E3 how do you like that decision I've
never played this before but I prepared
some lines like this in for the Olympian
and uh
I thought just play what I preferred but
objectively it's nothing because here
uh the reason why I played Rook E1 so I
because usually often white plays Bishop
F3 in Phil Brook E1
but anyway there is a Pedro key once and
some lines uh like if black plays Knight
C6 then at least my Bishop can stay on
the FM F1 yeah yeah yeah and he played
Knight bd7 A4 yeah I mean here okay it's
quite confusing
and stuff and then and no one really
knows what to do but it does seem like
you guys are following some uh top level
games as well I see bruzzone I see yeah
as well so this has been played before
yeah Bishop C wants to be such a weird
movement yes yes protects the pawn but
but I was slightly better here at some
point but then like like Bishop E2
takes yeah
yes just slightly better yeah but Knight
D1 is probably a terrible move but maybe
the idea with King H2 is terrible uh
a computer likes Knight D5 takes takes
Ed fabrics and then follow it up with C4
and Rook V5
yeah yeah and then before ah C4 yeah C4
Queen G3 V4 and white slightly better
like say Rook C7 let's get these three
pawns connected like that
um yeah 91 is too passive I didn't like
like black custom D5 by DSi probably the
even D5 works here so and you were also
spending a lot of time up to this point
falling behind 20 minutes on the clock
was time ever the concerning factor for
you during this game yeah for every game
this tournament yes two low on clock I
mean it's a bad sign that that means
you're not in good form when you spend
too much time but uh as I said yesterday
it's quite confusing also having
different time controls because like fee
determines this thing is an hour 40.
take some time to adjust from from one
to the other yeah I think here we have
one of the shortest time controls which
is 90 plus 30. but obviously I have to
speed up just but 91's not a good move
like I thought seems like it and then
you guys got to this position yeah he
could play D5 too yeah Bishop to C5 B4
F3 look to the bishop E3 and this moment
when he played the move D5 were you
getting concerned at all how did you
assess the position at this point well I
think sure I mean I wanted to try to
play for a win but obviously I'm risking
stuff
yeah it's a scary position for white
because after Rook takes A6 I assume he
has Rook cc8
rcd6 seems to be the right move yeah and
probably white can equalize so I played
Knight F2 obviously not by Rook defi8 is
a theory of error but it is it means
Bishop C5 it seems like yeah I don't
know what team is but Queen V7 is much
simpler huh and like it never loses or
maybe he can
but I was very I was very surprised by
Rook defeat because I think black I
think Sam was playing well until then
and I think after Bishop C5 you're
definitely gaining a pretty serious Edge
yeah I mean I'm up on up yeah and after
oh he just made through takes
yeah it's just winning
and once you guys got to this position
yeah it was a smooth conversion I would
say Fed Up on if we go back and move 38
after Queen D2 Rook h8 yeah I spent all
my time figuring out whether ed5 or 90.
I think D5 was correct yeah I get
getting three points is not
in one side it's no question that you
should just play it Wesley
congratulations an important Victory to
get back to 50 for you and start a new
yeah tomorrow it's my birthday and I
really don't know yet an early happy
birthday for you yeah
to you as well tomorrow yeah last year I
also played the a game the youth
championship for my birthday again
I do I was I was winning but you know
it's not so bad an elephant how do you
usually approach those games uh on your
birthday
yeah then I don't like is there anything
different to them
no not really I just
don't I think it's not a good idea to
play in your birthday I I played several
tournaments before on my birthday and uh
um I'll just give my best button for
it's clearly not ideal I don't know what
the author thinks if it's played and
after your birthday is actually the rest
day are you going to party at home
tomorrow night after the game or yeah
that that that's the plan I have a
birthday cake and birthday cake yeah
yeah and actually we celebrate my
birthday in Minnesota already before
this Thurman I had my breath infant
stuff
it's uh
because right after this is one
tournament after another but yeah but
it's it's nice it's uh it's
it's it's fun Wesley congratulations
we'll see you tomorrow thank you a quick
question for you Wesley uh it's one of
those things that you match up very very
well with Sam Shanklin you have a
marvelous score you've won four eight
draws today you've got your fifth
Victory against no losses uh can you
explain why the match-up is so favorable
for you
uh
I I don't really know I can't really
explain maybe I just know him so well I
played him many games yeah I didn't even
realize that
but
um
I I think
also family fun
expert in the opening but I I try to
avoid his preparation mostly when we
play
I I think I just know his style very
well like uh he's an excellent player
but he's also very uh
um
how do you call that he get he's very
streaky like he can play really well or
you can play really badly at some point
so
I just I I guess I kind of know how to
push hit buttons better than others and
uh when he gets slow on time or when he
gets too ambitious and then he makes uh
some oversights that's
when you pounce
all right uh congratulations uh
congratulations happy birthday no
presents from us
yeah I think I think every birthday
after 21 is pretty much the same but
right yeah
very good uh good luck uh for the rest
of the tournament more results are Sam
and Savion